[موسيقى]
هذه نظرة رائعة على النظرة الفاتحة
إلى الجمال المذهل
لرؤية رجل في الساعة الذهبية هي
رؤية المدينة بكل مجدها
حتى عندما تصبح المدينة الفظيعة شرقية
وغنية.
من قبل الرومان ،
إنه تذكير دراماتيكي بأنه على مدى
آلاف السنين تم غزو هذه الأرض من
قبل كل إمبراطورية
أو دكتاتور تقريبًا وترك كل منها
بصماته ، حيث كان
الآشوريون والموآبيون والفرس والرومان واليونانيون والبابليون
و  البيزنطيين الذين
كان لديك الأمويين ، وآسياس الفتح
والحروب الصليبية التي أدت إلى
الإمبراطورية العثمانية والانتداب البريطاني
أخيرًا وصلت إلى اليوم
والمملكة الأردنية الهاشمية
لم يكن هذا الجزء من العالم
بلا احتلال أبدًا كما يعرف التاريخ
متى  الحياة صعبة
ينتقل الناس إلى
الهجاء والكوميديا
ملها. نبيل هو
لك الهجاء الذي حكم ال
ردن منذ عقود ، تع
مون أنني بدأت مع هذا البلد ، أنا فق
20 عامًا.  إيه من البلد
الذي يسخر فيه من الملك ، رئيس
الوزراء صاحب النفوذ ،
لكن لا يوجد شيء عسكري في روحه
الدعابة
مثلما قال أوسكار وايلد إنه يمكنك إخبار
الناس بأي شيء طالما أنك تفعل ذلك
بروح الدعابة إذا لم تفعل ذلك بروح الدعابة.
أقتلك
ولكن هل تشكك في السلطة هنا
ومن الصواب أن تحكم
لا ، هذا ليس وظيفتي وعملي
حقًا هو إظهار أوجه القصور
وسلبيات حاكم
شعب رئيس وزراء الحكومة ولكن
ضمن الفكاهة
أنت سيدي
أنت.  ممثل
أنا
ممثل
لا
أنا nevillios marcos philadelphios أنا
حاكم هذه المنطقة فكر في نبيل
بهذه الطريقة الأصدقاء الأردنيون ضحكوا
كيف تسافر يا حصان أو عربة ، أنا
أسافر مع أي من السيد
أنا
أطير
هو واحد من هؤلاء
[  ضحك]
رجل هو مقر شركة الأردن للطاقة ،
وقد عرض لي أن يظهر لي
قاع البلاد في الواقع أسفل
العالم حيث سنأخذ المياه
لاستعادة حيويتنا وحيويتنا
[الموسيقى]
انظر إلينا
اثنين س  ld farts تمشي إلى البحر ،
إنه ليس مجرد بحر
، البحر الميت ،
نحن في أدنى نقطة
في الكوكب
في المرة الأخيرة التي كنت فيها هنا ، كان مستوى المياه
أعلى بكثير ، يجب أن
أقول إنني مصدوم
من
نعم  إنه أمر محزن للغاية
، حيث يؤدي التبخر والتعرية إلى
انخفاض مستوى سطح البحر بمقدار متر واحد على الأقل في السنة ،
ولكن في الوقت الحالي هناك الكثير من الماء
لرجلين مسنين غاضبين للاستحمام جيدًا ، حان الوقت
للتخلي عن الماء
في أي مكان في العالم يمكنك الجلوس عليه
الماء والشعور بالاسترخاء والشعور
بالسعادة ، أحاول الوقوف ،
لا أستطيع حتى أن أقول ، انظر إلى هذا
الخبير الذي يعبر ساقيه ،
فإن الطفو الفائق لدينا هو أحد الآثار الجانبية
لملح البحر الميت الذي يكون أكثر ملوحة بعشر
مرات إذا كنت  سوف
تبدو مياه البحر العادية بلا أيدٍ يا أمي
[موسيقى]
إنها تحبك الماء هنا
يعانقك تجرف قاع البحيرة ولكنك تحصل على
الوحل وهذا هو ما
أتدلك به وخنقه
هذا تدليك حقيقي
لم أحصل عليه من قبل  أنا نفسي
متمسك بكوني متمسكًا بي أنت تعلم أنني sti  ck معك بالتأكيد
هناك بعض الفوائد ،
إنه مثل مقشر ، أليس كذلك
نوعًا
ما ، لقد قلت الكلمة الصحيحة ، لقد أزلت
كل القمامة من بشرتك ، ما
عليك فعله هو الاستمرار في التنفس والتخلص من
التوتر ، نعم والأكسجين  هنا بقدر ما
تستطيع بالمناسبة ، يا فتى ، حسناً ،
ستحصل على أكسجين أكثر بنسبة 15 في المائة
15 هل هناك المزيد من الأوكسجين ومجانيًا
مجانًا ، وحكومة ألمانيا
لا تفرض عليك رسومًا مقابل هذا الأردن ،
هذا هو روح الأردن
التي يملؤها  أنت
ثم تترك بشرتك ناعمة ،
كيف هذا يعجبك أنها
دولة ذات قلب كبير تستوعب
الجميع لدينا 36
دولة
أه من اللاجئين ولكن
بالطبع الأردنيون والفلسطينيون بشكل أساسي ،
لذا إذا
جمعت هذه الأشياء معًا ، فستخلق
دينامو  الثقافات
المختلفة التي ربطت
البحر الميت ونبيل لديها الكثير من
القواسم المشتركة ، كلاهما قوي لا هوادة فيه
ويحول الشدائد إلى
صديق ومثل الأردن يستمر في الطفو ، يأتي
ما قد
تراه أين يمكنك  أنت تختبر
شيئًا جميلًا مثل
أنه حقًا
عالم يسوده السلام
[الموسيقى]
أنت